it's great to be joined today by James
Fallows who's a national correspondent
for the Atlantic and co-author with his
Weiss wife Deborah fallows of our towns
a 100,000 mile journey into the heart of
America it's so great to talk to you
James and the book is fascinating you
went all over the country 25 cities I
believe flying to most or all of them in
a single-engine plane which you which
you piloted talk to us a little bit
about the the sort of objective of the
project the objective was essentially
just to see the US and there was a
particular predicate for it which is
that from 2006 really until 2011 dev and
I were living in China and reporting for
the Atlantic and Ed was writing a book
called dreamy and Chinese and what we've
tried to do there even while being based
within the first Shanghai couple years
then Beijing was essentially to spend
all of our time on the road and going to
every little province and on ox carts
literally in trains and buses and in
river boats so we thought we came back
to the US and back to our home in DC
it'll be worth trying to do some of the
same reporting in the US and we had for
a long time flowing around this little
propeller plane a Cirrus sr22 with a
parachute for the whole plane and we
knew there are lots of places you could
get to that way you couldn't get to very
easily by interstates or by commercial
airlines so we just thought let's see
what kind of there is there if we want
to spend time in Sioux Falls South
Dakota or in Duluth Minnesota or in
Columbus Mississippi and so this ended
up going on for more than four years and
we sort of each step we took we we learn
new things I think that it's quite
common that there are people in the US
who assuming that you're sort of in in
the income bracket where you can afford
to do some travel who will often end up
becoming more familiar with other parts
of the world than the parts of their own
country that maybe aren't as accessible
to them I know that only in recent years
have I started to go to places like I
was in rural northern Indiana a few
months ago I've been to Ohio I've been
to some other places that wouldn't sort
of be natural vacation spots did
find that or do you find that this is a
pretty common phenomena that many
traveling Americans know foreign
countries better than they know the
different corners of the US I think
that's a great point and so a homely
example of that will be that over the
last forty years now my wife and I have
lived essentially half of our time in DC
and it's always true that people who are
visiting DC go out and see museums and
restaurants and new attraction that if
you're living in the place you don't get
around the city and I'm sure that's
that's true of any big town I think it's
also the case that that again Americans
who are in the traveling class when when
you're in the u.s. it's remarkable that
these a dozen hub airports Denver
Atlanta O'Hare San Francisco Seattle etc
get something like eighty percent of all
the commercial traffic because that's
how things are concentrated in various
ways and people there air travel takes
them to places that look familiar and
when you think of exploring the world
that might be places from Tuscany to if
you're adventuresome Singapore or
Southeast Asia or Australia or maybe
Africa more than South Dakota more than
Missouri more than Mississippi and so
that was part of our wanting to to
remedy that that imbalance to one of the
things I was struck by about six eight
months ago when I went to rural northern
Indiana this was sort of my first trip
to a really red area after the election
of Donald Trump other than maybe some
parts of the Florida Panhandle was that
even though I had kind of like an on
paper understanding of how and why it is
that people in some of these parts of
the country voted so overwhelmingly for
Donald Trump I still was passing a
certain degree of judgment on it and
after spending some time living in
northern or not living but visiting
northern rural Indiana I realized that
of course they voted for Donald Trump
once I understood that in a lot of these
places the only meeting point is the
mega evangelical church as an example
how of course that's how they ended up
voting and it really shifted my
perspective about just how different the
day-to-day lives are of people in
different parts of the country do you
have any anecdotes that
that that resonates with yes and are are
complimentary you know with an e rather
than I view to that is a different kind
of explanation and puzzle before the
what the results in the 2016 election
most of the places we ended up spending
time or in states that went for Donald
Trump we've here the plane states and we
were in both Allentown and Erie
Pennsylvania and the South you know
South Carolina Georgia Mississippi
Louisiana and it was on the one hand you
would think these places would not be
expressing outrage of the kind that was
normally diagnosed after the election in
that most places the economy was slowly
improving
most places Believe It or Not were being
quite inclusive cluesive of immigrants
for example in western Kansas population
is now mainly Latino in Ben Z devices
hometown of Holland Michigan that also
is majority of Latino now there's lots
of other indications I could give you of
something resembling a what a healthy
American civic fabric and yet when it
comes to talking about national politics
there was this really polarized extreme
bitter resentment driven feeling which
was embodied among other places some of
these megachurches so you could have in
Dodge City a place that went very
heavily for Donald Trump
but they're they're City finance manager
who is very popular there is a man named
or mister de la Rosa who's there in a
Dhaka waiver and they're their school
district is majority Latino and they're
voting bond issues to keep it going so
something in this disconnect between the
increasingly tribal and resentment
driven national politics which made
people think yes Trump is against our
enemies and we really heat Hillary
Clinton because she's crooked they would
vote that way national rate and the
texture of local life was was different
from that can you talk a little bit
about are there examples that you might
have for you know our audience is mostly
a progressive audience although they're
not just in cities on the coast they're
really spread out throughout the United
dates but we've heard this theme that if
you don't understand
rural America you don't understand why
Trump won what are some of the specifics
that maybe aren't understood about rural
America so I think there's one so I
should say his background that both my
wife and I although we've you know I
worked for the Atlantic forever and
we're part of quote in the national
media unquote we are from originally
small inland towns and felt as if this
was our territory I'm from a little
place called red ones in California
excuse me which is right next to San
Bernardino it's a part of it's very
different from coast of California Deb
is from a manufacturing town in Ohio
vermilion Ohio which is west of
Cleveland so we felt as if this was
these were places familiar from our
upbringing though not our current life
one I think understandable point of
resentment is less the familiar one of
economic dislocation which of course is
real or the opioids disaster which is of
course a disaster and becoming a
nationwide one it's what I think of as
two dimensionality versus three
dimensionality which is when there are
media or movie or print magazine or
newspaper discussions of Boston or of DC
or of San Francisco or of other big
centers the tone tends to be a sort of
richly three-dimensional portrayal of
people's motives and the complexities
there and people's agency and the ways
they're trying to respond to their
environments I think there is an
awareness by most of the interior of
America of being presented two
dimensionally that media people will go
there and go to a diner and find
somebody with a trump hat and say are
you still angry used to like Trump and
just presenting people as as victims and
objects and as being significant mainly
as a sort of background players in the
national political drama and I think
that most people in any part of the US
any part of the world right whether they
like to think of themselves
as these central characters in their own
lives and they have their own
independent drama and they're making
things better and worse and they have
they have agency and they have choice
and all the rest so I think that is one
I'll give you one illustration of that
there's a piece in a leading website
that I won't name right now that was
tracing this Russian spy it was recently
arrested the young woman Russian spy
when she went out to South Dakota the
Russian spy and was sort of a lying with
the NRI there and the piece was framed
as as here we are in a lightly populated
state most familiar as the home of Mount
Rushmore this was talking about the city
of Sioux Falls which actually we spent a
long time in it's a very leading tech
city Sioux Falls they have lots of
precision agriculture that comes from
there and so I think the people in Sioux
Falls will think what the hell we're
being portrayed as kind of these bit
players in the national media caricature
of what life is like away from Brooklyn
or DC so I think that that the be an
awareness of being presented as
one-dimensional or two-dimensional
figures rather than fully fleshed out
figures is an underappreciated one I'm
curious as far as your method of
transportation your single-engine
propeller plane with a parachute
were there any at any point during this
trip situations with the plane that did
not go as planned close calls
emergencies or was that not a dramatic
part of the trip in any way we tried to
minimize the drama this was the ex into
the flying world are they no drama Obama
policy we wanted to I haven't used to my
rating I've done this for a long time
but learn to fly in good weather but but
there's always something unexpected in a
small plane so we we ended up spending
the unexpected day in Murray Kentucky
home of Murray State University when
some sparkplug suddenly failed
we're over the desert of Arizona when
suddenly all navigation info just was
blotted out in the plane the GPS system
just went entirely down we were mine
early reassured when we heard on the air
traffic control
Albuquerque senator this is United 404
we've lost all our guidance it was what
it was the Air Force was testing an
entire jamming of the GPS system upon us
they hadn't let us know about this in
advance birthday so we had surprises but
no no emergencies well the book is
fascinating it's called our towns a 100
thousand mile journey into the heart of
America the book has two authors james
Fallows who's been speaking with us as
well as his wife Deborah fallows and I
encourage you to check out the book and
James I really appreciate you talking to
me today David I'm very grateful to your
interest and that of your audience so
saying thank you